okay take me to your guys is like you
guys are at the crib what is the show
you guys binge watch on Netflix together
like are you guys like hanging out
watching TV like throwing on [__]
Breaking Bad or something
I don't know it's called
[Music]
oh let me look at it's like this is
Wu-Tang the Wu-Tang show on Hulu yeah
yeah
you like Wu-Tang Clan Krishan is it with
that I don't know [__] about that Davis
is in it oh yeah I thought you was
talking about the lead one you don't
know the [__] about the real things man
do you feel like uh
you're more focused on the TV [__] or
the music [__] right now because if you
guys put some real records together you
know you got you got everything else
going
I mean I have records I just been
dropping
not in a rush not in a rush what about
you blue because obviously you're a very
successful artist many plaques I'm more
like are you kind of off the music [__]
giggles
but I don't know I'm trying to find my
way in the background like got this
restaurant thing I'm about to try
seeing if that work out
I'll be in the bed every day what
happened to uh your restaurant in Santa
Clarita I saw it got vandalized oh yeah
I don't even know I ain't even gonna
cause it's been closed for a while right
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why somebody
would want to vandalize an abandoned
building right
you know but we about to turn it into uh
the king of crabs I'm about to partner
up with them so you're gonna have like a
kind of the same type of vibe seafood
and [__] yeah it's gonna be seafood boil
more though like more with the bags yeah
yeah so you're kind of like off the rap
[__] low-key you're trying to make all
the all the all the other revenue
streams pop yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to
push her to do to fill in the blinks
like you know